if you can imagine that you were going
to go to school and you were going to
take the bus and the bus showed up but
there was no sign on that bus to tell
you where it was going to take you all
those signs on the bus has disappeared
so you'd get into the bus without having
any idea of where it might take you it
might take you to your school but it
might take you to your parents workplace
so imagine that you'd be Miss sorted and
that's a little bit what this process is
because of this process the passengers
the cargo they get to the right place
the school at the right time so you're
not late and you don't end up at the
playground or at your parents workplace
or somewhere else where you're not
supposed to be so this whole process
helps the cell sort proteins so the
information is moved to the right place